[Music]
hello
and welcome chess fans to our live
stream
there are more people here in person so
if you're in saint louis and you're not
making it you better run and make it for
the next hour
all right so uh hopefully everybody
had watched the today's game and
realized that duda became the
world cup champion which is not the
world champion just the world cup
champion
and um so he is doing uh
he's going to be able to get into the
candidates with a bunch of other people
and they're gonna you know fight to the
death and the winner of that
gets to play the winner between nepo and
carlson
which will be determined later in
december so it's a whole chess format
i definitely wanted to mention something
about the women's world cup because it
was very interesting the battle of
alex's
but we're not going to look at a game
from that today
but perhaps on wednesday we will be
doing that so if we're here
wednesday join us for the women's world
cup edition and
um so yeah actually i'm kind of curious
did anybody follow the world cup okay so
a lot of you did
yeah okay good good what about the chats
so yeah
we it was very it was very good uh so
i'm definitely going to be showing
one of the duda crossing games but the
first one that i'm showing
is actually not from this year it's
another time that judo managed to whoop
magnus
and it's kind of cool because i think
judah is definitely proving himself to
be a very
high level grandmaster so hopefully
we'll get to see him more often in grand
chess tours and stuff
later on i believe that's something
that's going to happen
for future but all right so let's get it
started
uh yeah also i again wanted to mention
that
um this specific game that i'm showing
right now
uh is actually in my upcoming book
that i wrote with my brother uh and
a lot of the analysis credit does go to
him as well for this game
just to have it out
the cat helps definitely but not as much
as my brother
uh all right so this was a very very
nice game
in the sense that i play this line
myself as white
so the fact that magnus played as black
like in such a high level chess
it's not necessarily um you know usually
think like these kind of
you know weird or second-class
quote-unquote openings
are not going to be played in high level
chess as
this but the surprising thing is that
they are
still being played and a lot of chess is
actually preparation
and opening and how well you can prepare
against your opponent
ah that helps i can hear myself now
so um yeah i felt like we were
trying to raise penguins here that's
always
somebody's always liking the super cold
weather
um do i know gm
oh my god i cannot read that i am
horrible with reading and
pronunciating so i'm not even gonna try
i do not know him
um why in you know face his face perhaps
but
not this specific name all right
um so i usually to always take a small
pause to
just kind of get a feeling of how my
audience is
doing so does anybody actually play this
opening as black
good choice though yeah
uh there's a lot of interesting ways to
play caro con
this is one of it but i feel like it's
um
i feel like there are much better ways
to try and give yourself
that you know equal chance of fighting
rather than this
but this i believe should should be all
prep if you're just playing this and
trying to figure
figure it out over the board don't do
that just know your openings it's like
it's like when you have an exam and a
teacher is like you know these between
these two
20 questions at least 10 of them will be
on the exam so
prepare for it and then you're like nah
who cares i'll just figure it out on the
exam it's the same thing you got to know
your openings
all right um so this is actually the
best way of playing it
knight e2 is also a possibility because
after 192
i mean i mean 92 is coming up either
right now or after
check so you it's just a matter of when
that will happen
so if you want you could do it earlier
if you you could just
do your coincidence um
and so h5 is what magnus did
to be fair i've had a lot of opponents
play h6 with me it makes
it so much easier to attack rather than
h5
i've had a lot of g6 g6 just
you just push pawn i don't think that's
something to worry about f5 is another
one but you can just take it
and it's it can be a little complicated
because
your queen is a little stranded you
can't just castle yet
so you have to spend more time trying to
figure out your next move which side the
castle how to
you know but black is just developing so
it could be an interesting choice for
black
but i'm a pawn eater so i would
definitely eat that so
if you play f5 you should know what
you're doing
all right so h5 um how do you think
white
should continue if you play this as
white you probably do
have a fair idea of how you're going to
unfold the position
but yes well i was going to ask you said
when they play h6 it makes it easier to
attack is that because of
like a v6 h6
that is ikea of the possibilities but if
you were to play h6 this is a new target
when you play h5 then my h4 h5 is kind
of stopped when you play h5 i don't
really have those g4s immediately
because of the bishop here too
but when you play h6 i can easily just
get my pieces rolling and
g4 is in the books later on
and um this is just easier weakness to
attack rather than when it's on h5 and
the bishop can you know stay on g4 and
also defend it and
uh just makes it more uncomfortable if
you have if you have to move this
it's better to be on h5 than h6 in this
specific opening
um because on h6 is also not really
doing anything specific that it write
yeah exactly yeah
all right h5 so how do you think we
should try to
form an attack
i guess the biggest question to answer
is which side do you want to castle
and i think that's another difference
between h5 and h6
that when with h6 you do have the
the choice of short castle more
seriously
it's not like you can't short castle now
but with h6 you're more
um inclined to consider it more
seriously when with h5 you're like ah
well if my short castle has already
punished five
yes peter i have grown to love pawn
eating
if you watch my streams on leachates
that i play people
i that that's been paying off why not
ponds are delicious little snacks
i believe we also developed a theme song
also this is super bright light so i
probably won't seem half of you so just
feel free to raise hands or just talk or
just do what you want i do see probably
a hand
yeah makes the most so your choice is to
do long cast though
yeah does anybody actually want short
castle
yeah i don't actually see much in
excitement about short castle
yeah short castle is definitely possible
but then your opponent can do immediate
h4 i want to do h3 and just you know
poke and probe some new
ideas for themselves not this is it
doesn't mean that short castle is a bad
idea but
why would you give your opponents that
enjoyment if you remember
my lessons are mainly about how to know
your opponent
how to inflict pain how to um make them
miserable it's all about that
it's all about how to stop opponents
rather than how to
find the super great moves for yourself
um
dancic i actually don't again i'm
i'm more familiar with the faces rather
than names because
i have two different worlds one is super
chess
involved one is super not just involved
so
all right bishop v3 i like it
let's say night out long castle okay now
b5 now what do we do
uh your farsi is good depending on how
how much google translator are you using
this is the same guy from last time i
don't remember man
it's been it's been a long week for me
i've been waking up at 6 00 am almost
every day
i don't recommend it
all right dang anything
also keep in mind black is magnus
carlsen
we had a lewis yesterday beating iranian
there we go
exactly so let's see if today you can
beat carlson
uh andrew so that's the thing uh if you
wanted to do h4s it's i feel like it's
something that you have to
be very cautious about because like when
you would play h4
at some point you want to play g4 but
then this bishop here would be very
annoying and you don't
get the chance to play f3 because then
your bishop is under attack so there's a
lot of like
things that are interconnected in order
to get g4 you need f3 but you can't get
f3 because of the e3 bishop so you kind
of gotta coordinate it better
h4 is a very um type of move that you
can't just take back so you have to just
you know be very sure about it and again
i am fairly certain that duda actually
had this in his preps when he played
because if he didn't
i would be very disappointed but
um you got to know your opening isn't
that such a high level
not even your openings all openings
what about d5 d5
possible um what's your idea
until we can be
okay so if d5 take you're going to take
on v5
i like that idea but um
you also don't necessarily have to take
and be be
be mindful of when you play d5 and those
pawns moving on the queen side
opponent's queen side
uh files and diagonals will get open
i'm not saying d5 is a bad move but i
just want you to
make sure that you consider opponent as
well
um i'm sorry what
d5 and then bishop f5
why are we trying to go to f5
to slow down his development of his nice
clear bishop
okay so you got a good bunch of plans
but
so i see okay d5 is a very interesting
move
and if take we potentially would want to
take over here
so let's think about what if not take
c6
yeah and if you take on b5 are you
comfortable with that
yeah okay so what about like if
so does everybody actually like d5
i'm saying one no i actually can't see
for most people how's the chat doing
g4 looks interesting so g4 is something
that you need to prepare more for if you
just play g4 right now
i can play h4 i can take it black wants
to close up you can't just
you know push if black can close up the
king side
then it can come attack on your queen
side
okay 9g threatening is a very slow
logical move
you're attacking the pawn if you push it
i'm going to go knight f5
it's a very fun mouse and you're
attacking a bunch of other
of the available pieces and
i think this could i think this is
actually one of the main lines that
people play
frequently um but on the other hand
i do know that there are some ideas with
queen c7s
h4s and queen c7s these ideas are also
quite valid
um rather
sooner rather than later but b5 is also
another thing that
what magnus did it so i can't really
talk bad about but
so d5 is actually what um duda did
but magnus is not going to take
because if take will take it back
and then you can just bring your queen
even more involved and then you know you
can
switch the queen on the bishop and then
you're actually going at a checkmate
you're looking at a nice checkmate
and uh you're correct about d5 so good
instincts
but what if d5 i play c5
so you want to eat the palm
okay
i'm gonna do a weird thing hold on how
do we like this from blacks
would you be happy if your opponent
takes on b5
okay no thank you laura
all right so i'm gonna flip it back
because we want to look at the winner's
all right so yeah your car equation b5
is does give black a little breathing
room but at the same time
um bishop b5 also is a free pawn and i
love three pawns i can't say no
so yes we were going to take it an
android p8 we got to defend this
bishop c6 is possible but you don't
necessarily know if you want your bishop
to get stuck
around here or would you ever want to uh
you know use this bishop for any other
purposes than just staying on c6
so c4 makes more sense you're also kind
of you know um
closing up that side as well a6
we gotta move this and rook e7 was
played which was
actually a move 15 of a super weird
sideline
is finally a novelty that magnus did i
wish i could you know just
ask him hey was this your preparation
but i don't think he's going to be very
happy about this specific game
you know losers are usually sore sorry
but uh yeah i don't really like talking
about my own games when i lose
let alone him if i could ever actually
get him on a microphone but anyways um
so
re7 now what do you think we should do
as white
if i ever stop giving you spoilers
so we have an extra pawn or are we have
a nice enough position
we got to develop more knight is one of
the candidates to
develop the rooks could be interesting
but the question that we're always going
to have is can i push some of these
pawns
well not this one but kind of partial
one of these pawns
so fh3 what is h4
if or if after h3 and then when you play
g4 they play h4
g3 now
yes but pawn takes
and then bishop can take and then you
are this guy is
dropping
um i don't really like the idea of
moving this
like this is way too slow and i feel
like we have we can make a better use of
the square for our knights
specifically and like if the knights can
get to g3 it's attacking h5
it's not trying to get to f5 this could
be a more interesting
square for our knight and black is not
completely hopeless so we don't have the
luxury of playing one
two three move just to you know break
that
out so that's why knight g3 is actually
a better choice
and it's also a safe one so
because turkey seven is a novelty it's
not necessarily like a super
cool novelty but because it's a novelty
it's highly likely that white who's a
2700
that was not prepared for this specific
move
so it makes sense to do the moves
such as knights g3 that are not too
demanding that are more
somewhat safer but you still have good
enough ideas about it so
it's also a little psychology part
behind it
all right so knight g3 uh if h4 okay
i'll just go over here and i'll be
eating some of your
available pieces so you're not going to
be doing that
um magnus 0.9 to e5 that was
a little uh
out of character knight b6 was a better
idea and the idea is after a nice b6
you're kind of forcing this bishop to go
to c6 that we didn't want to go for such
a long time
and now f5 you would try to sacrifice
the second pawn on your own terms
instead of giving it up um and now this
is also a mini trap
what if now what's uh why is
trying to hide the answers but i'm not
doing a good job
all right so uh now after knight f5 why
is light five a bad move
yeah true you're gonna take it and then
after take you're just going to lose
this guy
and then momentum piece activity space
initiative all those stuff that we
always talk about
are right here
there's a piece of gum all right so
yeah so knight f5 is not a good choice
bishop g5 would be better and then
uh so the the main idea is like it's not
like black is
having such a cool advantage right now
but black is kind of pushing black
is uh forcing white's pieces to go into
uncomfortable positions
and black is gaining space for that one
pawn that he lost earlier
so he's trying to balance out the
playing field
level up level out balance out whatever
he's trying to make it more
interesting for himself uh so yeah
that's why knight b6 would be a better
choice because
attacking and gaining tempos and all
those fun stuff that we always talk
about all right anyways he played knight
e5
it's the same like destination but
this is the problem the problem with
this is that now i could simply move
this bishop away
or i could simply you know stop this
stop this attack on my c4 or
as do that in the game knight e4 however
knight e4 looks pretty nice but it's not
necessarily the best one
because now you get to double up your
rooks
and now this is more pressure than it
would be so
if you had seen this it would make more
sense to play bishop d2 first
but again understandably it's you know
kind of weird to just play like a weird
bishop d2
when you don't have to uh another way
you could consider
playing bishop d2 is that you stop queen
a5s
you stop these and you want to do f4
potentially
so not an easy move i i admit to that
but it's also not that hard shouldn't be
that hard for 2700 plus actually 27.50
plus let's be more precise
so yeah um knight e4 was played and then
magnus got some activity
finally bishop d2 was played now how do
we feel about
knight takes d6 good bad
i'm sorry what so i'd rather have the
knife and um
so you prefer not to take it yeah okay
i i agree with that um and if the queen
takes then what do we do
yeah bishop d2 we're going to kick this
guy away
and slightly uncomfortable but there is
still a nice
balance on the position it's hard for
white
to uh go about it because black has a
lot of different ideas coming up
but it doesn't mean that white's
hopeless it's a it's a very interesting
flight for both sides
that's why that earlier bishop d2 would
make more sense because
another again another way to look at it
this this is something
that could create a nice sacrifice for
black so
white could take that away from him see
figure out what your opponent wants and
block it
all right so this is actually what
happened in the real game
okay we're going to defend this poor guy
over here and white
uh got it slightly lucky because magnus
made his mistake with h4
now instead of h4 knights g4 was a
better
knight g4 was a better plan now after
knights g4 f2 is the real target right
because i want to
take knight takes f2 and bring more
pressure to your e4 so
white to move what do you think we
should do
um if you play f3 i could still point
knight f2
f2 possibly
okay well
[Music]
well that's the thing we're trying to
figure out what can whites do
i'm having a suggestion of f3 both in
chat and in real life i'm having a
rookie two suggestion i think it's kind
of between these two
um if f3 i think knight f2 is definitely
possible
and this exchange it would work
if there was like a already queen on b6
so black as it moves too short
so that's why it's a better idea to take
it already
so that your knights can stay in a
better spot and then you can try to
relocate your clean
and these black squares are super
just super weak and white's pawn
structure is just up in the air so black
has enough compensation for the
sacrifice that he made earlier
very nice checkmate idea coming up but
that doesn't necessarily mean that
white's super lost okay now it's super
lost
there we go one more move now it's super
lost
but uh right now white doesn't have to
be
there is still a good fight for both
sides
uh argue it's understandable that
we would prefer to be black because of
the peace activity and the space
and the super weapon structure but well
white is not completely hopeless there
is still a very good fight going on
so with that in mind let's just go a lot
back
and look at a position that minus did
not do the most accurate if he played h4
which is um kind of interesting because
you know from the world champion you
would always expect to
get super moves not them not in
accuracies
but i'm here to tell you that it's not
true
uh so now after h4 what do you think we
should do as
white
i don't say no to h3 oh
i'm really liking this f4 move but
that's something that's
i'm having trouble hearing
yeah it's a logical move this knight g4
was bothering us so we can stop it yeah
i think s3 is a logical move and it
might not be the super necessary
then computer might love f4 or rookie 3
way more
well not way more but computer might
find them uh
more easy to play but h3 is a very good
practical move knight g4 was bothering
you you take it away
all right so um now we can do this rick
e3
and all right now what
are we finally ready to push the jeep on
yeah that's something exactly that's
something we've been kind of struggling
with when to do it for like the
last 10 moves
so peter in the chat i don't know if
rook
g1 is necessary also eduardo you miss my
h
this is the rakshani there's okay which
everybody kind of
messes miss my
h's
i don't know about rook f3 i mean i see
your idea but i can just check you over
here
i don't really know look after you just
the
very up in the air i think this is the
easiest way to punish white
so let's go with the g4 all right g4
uh ampersand might not be the smartest
choice
because you simply take back if
my mouse lets me and then you move this
knight and now i can simply bring this
rook
and eventually i'm gonna keep pushing
these pawns but more importantly
these pawns are actually defending all
of these squares that your pieces can
poke through
so that's the part that i really do like
about
all right so
yes but do you want to answer yourself
oh you want to take that now do you
still want to answer yourself
do you want to answer to yourself no
do i want to go yeah
usually my camp kids loves it when they
correct them william
answered themselves i picked up that
habit from there
yes
doing good
all right yeah so g4 it is the idea is
that if you also take over here
i'm most definitely going to take this
and whoa and now
i have a knight in exchange for
one pawn yeah so it's not even worth it
for black yeah cause black gave up too
many pawns already
the you know there was one one missing
over here
and uh even if you do eat these two
there's still this beautiful night so
it's not worth it for black and so
yeah taking on poison
is not a good choice so magnus
is bishop
why would i give up my bishop
um
i hear you but the problem is that this
queen now it's
too dangerous uh it has two
maybe that's awesome
i couldn't figure out myself uh no the
the the problem
the the logical problem without even
calculating
this is that you actively make your
opponent's pieces better
and you actively push your own pieces
that are defending your king away
you don't have to check my threads your
rook is still sitting on the first rank
if your rook was like on
the second rank yeah i would do this but
now opponent does bishop e5 you can
defend
can begin a new type of attack line so i
wouldn't really um
think too much about it it's a good idea
to just keep an eye out for when can we
do this knight f6
but not at the cost of like
giving two pieces just to eat f5 and
getting opponents pieces more activated
but yeah
good good idea to keep an eye out on
this all right so g4
bishop moves away and now is the time to
run with the king
it's a little weird because we don't
necessarily you know we always castle
and then we were like okay so i castle
my king is safe
but now we're on cat we're on castling
d castling i don't even know what's with
the english
way for that b but anyways we're trying
to run with the king
and um so queen d7 is the one that makes
the most sense
for different reasons reason number one
your king
um is going to be trying to
run to either the queen's either stay in
the center so
your queen on d8 is very useless uh your
queen on d8 is never going to
come to a5 or anything so because we
have a dark squared visual it makes
sense for
the queen to want to go to light square
to
form some sort of bond in there with
those white squares other than just
keeping the dark squares because
well there's this bishop so queen d7
makes uh that side of like strategic
logical sense
and with the the calculation side of it
there is potential for f5
then trying to open up some parts of the
center
all right so magnus made another
inaccuracy god i love this game
and template f5
now after f5
what should white do and
sorry what possible
uh but why
yeah i think uh either taking either
oops
either taking this first or taking it's
um
that should be good taking this first
could
also be beneficial as the sense that now
because the g
file is open you can also shift this
over and
making shish kebab but
um but i think taking on d6 is much more
straightforward
take back and then we can take yeah
three pounds hey you're doing my
strategy of eating free pawns
nice nice and
okay now check now what should we do
actually this is a very silly question
we should just push the pawn so i'm just
going to do that
i mean king e1 doesn't really make sense
right and king
c1 doesn't really make sense either so
let's just do the f3 alright so now
queen
f6 now what do we do
i'm surprised this game took so long
i mean there's still like 30 more moves
on here i believe
i'm going to give you guys maybe just
another minute because i see good a lot
of good ideas but
um there's nothing wrong with queen a1
bishop c1 if you have to defend the
bishop
on c1 that's okay
and also peter in the chat uh
magnus did lose this game and it was in
norway so i'm
guessing he lost half his hair after
this but
why is the man from behind silent
there's not that
milo you said ghosts
all right now it wants to double the
rooks
i'm not so sure i mean the
my issue with rookie one is
okay let's do this check you bring it
back then i'll give this check
and it could give black a little
happiness i don't want happy opponents
i believe black white is still much
better
but um
why would i give any type of slippery
slopes to the opponents
so what i think is the most accurate way
there are there are a bunch of good ways
well which one do you think
takes away a lot of opportunities that
black has
oh yes milo this is an in-person class
that
we are also streaming and keeping an eye
on the chat
too so yeah there are people here
talking
to me
i i i can't hear i need louder sorry oh
i'm just saying bishop's teacher you
look so attractive
i don't think you're wrong but i need
more so what do you think is the best
idea for black when you play bishop c3
i'm sorry what
bishop yes but what do you think what's
the best idea for black after bishop c3
possibly
yeah maybe queen b6 wanted to go to
queen b1 that's the one that does make
sense right because after queen b1 your
h1 rook is under attack
um somebody's gut wants to simplify it
good for you yeah i see rook b3 but the
problem with repeater you're forgetting
about taking on f3 potentially
so after take you kind of got to take it
to the queen and then you're losing this
so you still do have some um
some advantage but you kind of blow it
this is like plus six that one is barely
plus one
bishop c3 is possible but again
not the most accurate but i guess we
have to take that up with duda
so the most accurate one is actually
queen e4
understandably hard to find the idea is
simple i want to eat your knight and if
you give me check i'll block
it and if you bring the rook now i'll
play king d2
and then rook on c1 defending
no checks even if you try to be cute
about it now i'll just bring my queen
back
now you're kind of forced to exchange
queens if you try not to then i'll still
force you
cool stuff all right um
so yeah king d2 was the the
the real way to go about it but anyway
so
uh queen e4 is the best idea however
bishop c3 was played in the game
and queen g5 now do that is messing it
up a little bit but a little bit
that's always something that happens
even when i was playing just like
silly games um with the viewers like
just 960 or whatever whenever i would
see
a move then then i wouldn't do it but
then i was like ah that was a good move
that was about the last move
that would mess with your head so i can
hypothesize that that's what was
happening to do that too he would see
like oh this is such a good move oh i
just didn't do it okay now i'll do it
now but that kind of blew the advantage
and um so yeah the the other way to
consider it is this tricky one
is something that makes a lot of sense
you just want to change the rooks uh
somebody said oh yeah
peter in the chat is saying that he
wants to simplify it exactly
we are going to try our best to simplify
keep in mind bishop 3 is coming so you
can't just
take over there then you would lose
so trying to simplify trying to simplify
that is uh the best the most accurate
one that would give white the maximum
advantage however queen e4
was played now a little too late queen
g2
rookie one and magnus decided to
give us this beautiful gift of a weird
game and he took queen takes a2
now what do you think is the best move
for black
right
you don't have a problem with me eating
your night
could i get your knight can i check on
me yes
what about bishop
wait what oh f3
oh yeah okay so official takes f3 you
just rock days
but my coin is here right and then
if you had another bishop here maybe
no um f6 is actually the best one it's
not that easy to find and the idea is
that white gets the chance to just
push and black can't do anything about
it
but this does give black
the best chance of um
creating some counter play yeah
okay oh but can i just come back okay
here i mean it's a pawn and this is not
okay so to be fair eating this pawn is
better than eating on a2 so
i you played better than magnus good job
yeah so queen a2 not a very uh
smart choice i really hope i don't get a
seat in the season order
i'm kidding um
anyway so queen a2 what should we do as
white now
one
i have six
yeah i think the biggest problem is that
right now white
uh has this problem with rook b1 so you
have to defuse that bomb
yep that's what makes the most sense ah
yeah
and now if you eat the other pawn now
what do we do
maybe
but keep in mind that this is also
falling down
also rookie ford is that
yeah yeah let's just exchange these
rooks up
and uh i mean if he were to take
it it's kind of the similar issues now
there's also f6 type one there
but actually let's let me uh how do i
actually too late i already showed a
good never mind
so if this were to happen why
to move what do you think we should do
try to ignore the analysis up there
to your best of abilities
yep loose pieces
check boom nice
so i believe that's why he didn't so
king h7
now what did we do
can we just eat that drug
okay i agree i think your hair scratched
the mic or something
can't do anything about it i got a lot
of hair
potentially i keep finding some of it in
my mask
he finally forgave me yeah
no for the vet from yesterday yeah
all right so let's say they eat our pawn
too now what do we do
so for the new audience i have a very
chubby cat
he's and he has an amazing dog-like
personality without the dog
messiness so it's perfect and
he likes to go out and play and he's on
the cover of my book too
i did not request that but i'm very
happy about it and
we had a nice chicago trip together he
was such a
such a sweetheart but then we had a vet
visit because i'm trying to fly him to
london
so we're kind of he was there most of
the day yesterday
so he when he came home he was very just
like you know when you have a fight with
a friend and they're just like giving
you the culture then he was like that
with me
he always sleeps on the bed that night
he did not
but in the morning he came and he purred
and he was like okay i'm over it let's
get out
yeah so what to do
he owns me all right back to the chest
of it because if you let me talk about
peachy i'll never stop and we will keep
showing you pictures and that
this class will go a whole different
direction pc studies
pc 101 oh i i'm way past the intro class
oh yes that is true you could ta in that
class
all right so um
how can doodah continue to beat up
magnus
oh
um
so hold on what's the problem with king
c1 let's
solve that first because right now we
have an extra rook and extra exchange
so we have the luxury of giving some of
it up
so which one do you think is safer queen
d2 or king c1
uh
true and let's say you go king b1
and then we take it back with the bishop
we still have that extra rook on b8
i could also be trying my best to trick
you
so i do feel tricked or
i feel like we should have like at the
one of those
little cams from here to show the
audience to the youtube too
i was seeing a lot of fun facial
expression like uh do i feel tricked
yeah so do you guys feel joked about
king c1 or
so you think easy one is a good move
i need my evil laughter button
yeah so unfortunately
kc1 would magnus would slip
out not fully they would still get a
half
point probably um
but see the problem is now this super
super nasty queen e5
it's really hard to even explain it but
this is the only move because now
i'm going to eat one of your pieces and
the one that i
eat most likely the bishop that i eat
now my bishop is going to eat your other
pawns too and your king is having
problems so
black gets the chance to um get slippery
and yep definitely allow this to happen
understandably so queen d2 is the better
choice
now magnus two duda ran magnus took
do the attacked magnus checked
do the rant and it's a very nice team
now the fun part is taking is something
that's
sorry taking that's something that was
considered i did it one move early sorry
but the problem now is check and i'll
pick this
up this should still have some decent
advantage
but you know i don't really want
to have to use the word decent
when i talk about advantage i want it to
be full advantage bloody
murder done so um
yeah now this is not the only way you
could do like a cool queen da
to thread some nice checkmates here this
would still
the result in a cool win however
um rookie 2 duh is the best move but you
have to follow it with the best idea
too so 92 king up
take take queen f4 this should be a
relatively easy win
to be fair taking is something we could
also strongly consider
because even if you give up that
exchange even if you go
give up the rook in exchange for the
bishop this is
we have enough material to easily win
this
but if you want to be fully sure you
might
as well keep your extra material as duda
did
and i don't really see much hope for
magnus i mean he could eat the pond or
something
but this is um this is really
sad way for magnets to
lose this game i'm just gonna scroll
through this
because these are i don't have much
comments to give for them because this
is a
magnus attacking something very basic
and do those just covering it
you guys keep trying to keep his pieces
magnus is attacking it it's just a
like a waltz i don't know how to comment
on that either
finally we got rid of this bishop and we
are going to eat some of these pawns
please okay finally we ate the pawn
another nice check and another nice
check
and we are trying to promote our king
can we please okay finally exchange the
queen's weight
this should also be winning enough
because your pawn is advanced
again enough king moves and you can't
just push because it'll bring the rook
so you would have to uh like advance
pawn first
and then i my pawn is fast enough even
if you push i'll just go behind it even
if you push i'll just push
and i'll be fast enough g2 doesn't
really work either i'll just make a
queen
if you make a queen uh check
i have a queen and a rook and i have the
first check but anyways if you want to
avoid these we don't have to exchange
queen we can just give this check and
have a much cleaner win
but yeah this was a very fun game i
specifically enjoyed it because it's on
my book
and and i always like it when
people win against higher rated grand
masters specifically the top 10 so
when the people beat magnus it's
interesting for me
i don't sit there and do evil after but
i definitely will show the game
and we are going to take a quick break
and be back and watch duda beat magnus
again
different game uh same results uh
so for the next five minutes
or so enjoy a little break and
be here because we're not gonna stop the
stream we're just pausing it
and we are gonna be looking at a very
cool
short video of pepe doing the same game
just in a very shorter way all right see
you guys in five minutes
and actually he was thinking he was
winning he thought he was winning in
this position
because it's not easy for one because
there is rook be one coming
and if you play queen c2 it looks like
black can take on c4
right and then there's some check on ea
i'll just take in h7
looks like black skin is fine
queen e5 there is checkmate on b1 so you
cannot go for this
i arrived first with rook b1
so just try to find the solution i was
very impressed because duda found this
solution extremely quickly
in that game
so any ideas
queen c2 and if i take on c4
what happens queen c2 i just take on c4
and now what looks like black's winning
you gotta find something concrete
yeah queen c2 but then what queen takes
e4
and uh it's not clear
rook e8 takes
take skin h7 and then
and then what you are almost there
you are almost there bishop d2 i mean
this is too sad yeah
it's just rook b2 for example this is
just losing look at
how the bar had a heart attack after
bishop d2
that's right guys you saw that pretty
amazing combination i mean i was very
impressed
when duda played extremely fast queen c2
here in this position
magnus thought he was winning but the
problem with queen c4
is that there is this nice tactical shot
rookie 8
now magnus played king h7 because he
realized
that if he takes on e8
then there is rookie 8 king h7
and then the final blow
the final shot come on
defeat magnus carlsen beat magnus
skeleton how do you do it
rouge 8 that's right rook h8 fantastic
move
king takes h8 and bishop g7
sayonara baby king takes c7 queen takes
c4
and black has to resign
so that's why magnus carlsen already
noticed that he was losing actually
after this trick on h8
that's why he tried key h7 okay
rook b8 and then he's i mean he's
completely lost
he kept fighting in this position he
took on d5
queen d2 fischer takes f3
king c1 and queen takes f5 i mean
dude is so much material up yeah it's
got like two rooks for one night
it's true that the king is a little bit
shaky on c1 but
you know this is just uh too much
material so let's see how
the game finished so rookie three in
this position attacking the bishop
and covering d3 which was magnus scouts
and threat
let's say if you play something stupid
like a5 knight d3 and probably
black's winning so you gotta be careful
till the end of the game
so um
rookie three knight e2 from magnus
carlsen king b2
knight takes c3 for this
not much going on queen takes c3
attacking the bishop queen four from
magnus cassin attacking the rook on
b8 queen d3 check f5
facundo this time not enough to solve
black's problems
rook fade okay discontinued a little bit
more
but i mean it's not really interesting
because the game is completely lost for
magnus carlsen
he took on e4 finally sacrificing an
exchange
and now is only one recap in this game
some more checks you can always check
for a few more moves but after king a5
took on a6 now magnus carlsen tried to
push the pawns but this is just
too much and finally he resigned because
he was
actually taking the queen on f5 next
move
okay so this was the game that
ended magnus cause an unbeaten strike of
125 moves
two years without losing a single game
in a classical
chess tournament facing 2700 players
all the time and we have to say that
he actually lost a second game in this
uh same tournament against uh
levon aronia we actually analyzed that
game the other day in the class
in the end game class so basically
magnus carson losing two games
in one tournament this is not a very
common thing to see
okay guys so it's been a fantastic
pleasure to be here with all of you
i i guess i'll come back to the youtube
channel in couple of days
for the next lectures where we'll have i
think a chess for rookies
chess for nights and uh
puzzle paradise as well where we'll be
solving some interesting puzzles so
i hope you guys have a nice evening and
take care yes stay healthy that's a more
important thing
just take care guys see you
whoa oh hello
how's it going so hopefully you are
enjoying this ah so on this one i
uh made a small inaccuracy and magnus
did not get whooped on this one
he got i mean i guess he got whooped
overall
but the main point that we wanted to
mention
and i kind of forgot and i was reminded
of is
that the previous game that we showed
was the first game that kind of magnus
lost
after a year and how long it was 125
games okay so 125 games
so more than a year so it was um
extra spicy for him oh my god did they
cry
poor guy anyway so um i really want to
show this game that he had
between duda and magnus and there's
another game that i really really really
want to show but i don't know if we'll
have time for so i'm
just going to dream small and show this
game too
so this is actually a game that was
played uh
three days ago in world cup it this this
specific game ain't gonna draw but
we can live with that too um there is
another game that magnus played at with
doodle and do the one
you can see that on our same channel
that i believe caleb did it like i'm 99
percent sure
but this was done a few days ago as well
so well feel free to enjoy a different
game between duda and magnus there
i'm gonna go ahead and get started we'll
have that link up for you
uh in a little bit too so this was
again a very fun opening i believe
magnus kind of learned his lesson
he stopped playing weird openings
against duda
but again the only time will tell if
he will continue to do these super cool
openings or not
anyways uh we have a very normal lopez
i remember when i was just beginning to
try my best to form new theories as
black
i ended up on this uh this is like back
in 2013
14 15 those years these d6 and these
g6 these are super popular so if you are
looking for a very interesting
way to um
exactly to apply a little weird openings
and get your opponent slightly busted in
the open just to get them thinking it's
not going to be like a super win
out of the opening but if you're going
to make sure that you have a better
preparation at the opening
that than your opponent in the opening
this
d6 g6 97 these are very little
uh devilish tricks so
i think magnus is past those though and
we have a very very very normal
uh lopez going on so who actually plays
this as white
or black okay i see a lot of at least
three hands
i can't see back there well all right
and hopefully more in the chat so that's
something to consider
about this how many people how big of a
popularity this opening actually has um
so how do i
ask how do i feel about d5 but my hands
my fingers are slightly frozen so i
can't really
feel when i move oops
that's okay i have bad circulation in my
hands and feet i had actually my one of
my feet got slightly blue
the other day go to a doctor
i've been to the doctor
i also said i'm trying to become a
doctor here's good motives why do you
want to become a doctor because i have
blue extremities
yeah all right um
so now after d5
take take take take and here is the
first position i wanna ah
i wanna stop at all right e5 pawn
can we eat yay
i always do it and then usually
sorry what though i always do it and
then usually regret it oh okay you
always eat the pond unusually regret it
i mean that is in the marshall bamboo
oh yeah
all right so yes that's kind of general
idea that we want to
be aware of um
yeah so take take and
rick takes e5
again kind of a weird martial
type of deal i guess anti-martial wait
no this is marshall right
well if and then it turned into sort of
yeah
we're having a slight logistic roadblock
so this is anti-marshal but then it kind
of turned into a marshal
anyways there's a pawn sacrifice on the
board and uh
pieces are gonna start flying around
okay
um so one thing that i definitely did
want to do is
do a small evaluation on this game
because this game is not
as exciting
as the previous game the previous game
was so much tactics so much sacrifice
this one is still very very interesting
especially because we know that overall
dude
won the whole thing and magnus became
third which is really funny when you
think
about it but the
the the part that we care about more
than the
sadness of magnus is that um
the evaluation of this position so
what's going on white
black who do we want to be
well it does have an extra pawn but
is it worth it thinking opening the side
sorry what i already saw oh that's okay
that's why i'm asking a question you
need more than the engine to answer
wait when was this i think it was a few
days ago i was playing um
no no i was playing a game that i felt
like i was playing with the engine
so it was very fun i got really wrecked
but towards the end when they were in
lower time they started messing up
so it was very fun that's usually how
you know
anywho uh
so i'm not this i'm not asking for moves
at the moment because well right now
black could eat my rook so i gotta move
the rook that's not the question
uh what i want is um
what i want is
evaluation who is better white or black
and i don't mean like i don't mean that
this ups that this number
i mean the the criteria for evaluation
material king safety space
center all those fun stuff
i mean there's extra pond so you know
who i like
okay all right so um
sure yeah all right so let's just get
this trick away
and i'll ask the same question in a few
moves again
so black does have an interesting
counter-attack
going on but i don't know if it's enough
to
have it as a full compensation for the
pawn so
it really just depends on how the
players will continue
and the fun part is that now after
17 moves so finally on move 18 there is
a small novelty with queen f1
alright so how do we feel about
exchanging queens
true but it's not going to be that easy
because we still have a lot of
like we still got to get the knight on
the bishop so it's not
going to be a very clean cut win
sure
but the black's also kind of trying to
attack
so let me ask you a different question
what if i just eat this
loose pieces
yeah peter you got it peter from the
chat
is there peter here okay
you never know people here could be
still talking in the chat
yep yuwan you got it too wait
yuan is the swedish way of saying a
swedish norwegian adam
not sure how to say this
yeah good job lose pieces
ben feingold would be very proud of you
all right
yeah and if you weren't to if you wanted
to be more
um i guess cool and
try to form new attacks over there this
is something that
black would enjoy with f5
and then you got to move the stroke and
then f4 and
we'll see you next game so
that actually would give black clear
advantage so queen f1 makes perfect
sense
you um black proved
to be perfectly fine in the opening
and for the cost of a pawn
so now we're gonna try our chances the
end game
but the other the one problem is that
some like we have these type of
strategies when we play with
lower-directed opponents depending on
how much lower they are
if there's like if i'm playing a 1900
they're like a 2100
and they're super good in the opening
amazing in the middle game then they
must suck in the end game otherwise that
would be like 2 500.
so that's one way that a lot of the a
lot of the
high-rated players kind of like choose
how to
which part of the game to kind of bust
you in
so but with magnus i don't think this
technique would work
so um yeah i don't really know how
one would do any type of strategies
versus magnus
so yeah um the only
the only way that you could actually
play against these two grandmaster super
grand wrestlers just to play chess
and uh i mentioned super grandmasters
because i
when i was like twenty one hundred
twenty two hundred twenty three hundred
and four hundred all of these
ratings when i was playing a grand
master that was like twenty five hundred
uh or like early twenty six hundreds it
was easier for me
to prepare some opening that i felt like
i was better prepared than than they
were but when you're playing a 2700 it's
a whole different class
they're much more you cannot bust them
in the openings
they're gonna know better than you
unfortunately
if you have any experience with that in
the chat or in real life please do let
me know
but that's like that's like a different
class of chess
so i like busting my opponents in the
opening
that's always the the best way anywho
bishop f5 all right now
the one thing that i don't know how i
felt about was
here dude i played knight d2 whereas you
don't necessarily need to give up the
rook so i don't know if i would give up
the rook but then again i'm not duda
our first names uh our last names do
start with d
but that's that's as close as it gets
uh yeah rook d1 or e1 is something
i felt a little bit better about
rather than knight d2 but i understand
why knight d2
is something that you would want to play
you got to get your pieces out
out because if your pieces are just
sitting in the first rank
and you might as well just you know push
them off the board
anyways uh let's eat some ponds
all right now are we gonna exchange
these rooks or not
[Music]
so for white would you want to exchange
your rooks off yes i mean
i said no based on what i think is the
correct principle
is that right what's the quiet principle
i was asking if the
player with the two ropes uh
would like to exchange oh yeah because i
have two of something you have one of it
so if we exchange one of it off i have
something that you don't have
i'll have a rook that you don't have
yeah they can't yes
but just like the super like super
simplified way of thinking about it
but also the logistics behind it uh now
this rook can
you know just go from behind and stab me
whereas now i would you know have to oh
my god this is looking so sad
and this is a good bye bye party for
pawns
oh yeah i don't want to look at this
this is too depressing
but all my pawns are about to fall and
there is still a fight to be done it's
not super hopeless but
i don't want to put myself in a position
that i have to start praying to god
for and start making deals is it just me
or when you're like super desperate
you're like oh god i please
i'll be a good girl i won't do this or
that
i yeah i remember when i was growing up
and
i did a lot of those middle of the game
oh my god
oh boy anyways so try your best to not
need to pray
before during a game before game after
game i understandable during the game
start to negotiate if you let me win
i'll
go to prayers five times a day or
whatever that's that's
that's when you know you need to
take a pause from chess anyways uh all
right so rook d1
now magnus is a tough nut so he's
not going to just let you eat the knight
and
uh just exchange pieces up so this is in
magnus's interest to keep this knight on
the board so
it's called a move and a prayer is that
a thing
i thought that's just called this this
when you're like desperate
that's this desperation i don't know
yeah anyways knight to b6
now what do we do also while i'm asking
you what do we do
i want to do another evaluation so
would you want to be white or black
white okay good good um
so now that i've asked that my other
question is
as whites realistically are you
fighting for a draw or for a whim
and i know that's a very hard hard
question to try to answer because
sometimes you know you're kind of
fighting for it
equality and draw but you're hoping for
a win but sometimes you're actually
fighting for a win
and you're also fine with the draw so
in this position do you think white is
realistically fighting for
a win and like is okay with the draw but
it's like or is okay with a draw but
he's hoping for a win
i guess the whole thing is where the
gods and disney fairy tales would come
along
we got a tooth fairy we need to have a
chess fairy
one of my students is seven she's losing
her teeth
so whenever we skype she's like i lost i
lost another one the truth fairy came
and i don't know how to tell her about
santa so i'm just gonna
probably just let the parents out yeah
yeah
no around around christmas she was so
excited and
it was very interesting for me because
my kid ain't gonna know about santa i
mean i'll break the deal
much easier when i have if i have one
all right let's get back to
this part of it all i care about right
now is peachy you know he knows there is
no
tooth fairy no santa there is a tuna
gato
all right so uh the let's get my head
back to the chest of it so
win lose draw okay nobody was fighting
for a lose so win
i a think mike is more likely to win if
anybody
okay so you are kind of wait so are you
fighting for equality but hoping for a
win or are you fighting for a win
you're fine with the draw
okay
fair point i'm not
understandably anybody else
i see a lot of the chat also do like
white and are
just kind of saying why through wind
i mean
he's also playing chess bonzo and wait
where did lewis go he was the one who
had the fun with our onion oh my god
we're creating such cool rumors
this might actually be a fun sting
all right so yes we are kind of um
so uh but a better way to look at it is
that white's position has the better
chance of
getting advanced so your pieces have a
slightly better chance of
being in better uh written and
coordination
because of the pawn structure that black
has
so that's i think the only reason that i
would like white and i would want to
um be white right now so
rookie one knight e4
knight e4 also does make some sense
because you are
trying to create really cool ideas there
but anyways rookie one also a good
choice the
the only uh not the only the main thing
that i do like about rookie one is there
is no rookie 8 because of the
f7 pawn mixness right
so rookie 1 knight c4 take take
and okay now how do we feel
do you think it was a good idea for
whites to
exchange these black really wanted it
because he did it at the cost of
the double pawn so
oh there are more people on the back i
didn't see sorry
this light is extremely bright
actually there's three sorry okay
interesting
i don't like when my opponent has
knights
okay personal choice
i mean it's understandable so um
also i can't really see how many people
are watching this i thought i could but
anywho oh my god i lost the chat nope
the chat is
back okay
um so everybody happy with white
because the main thing in this game is
not tactics or it's not the super
strategy that the players did
it's the the rhythm of the pieces and
how you get to maneuver them
and how you are trying to
advance your position as best as you can
so
knight f3 rock moves we would ideally
want to keep this but rookie 2 is not
the way because
now you can simply bring your k2 and
it's not really going to save your pawn
anyways
so knight e5 boom boom
and all right another small
evaluation white or black
i'm going to keep asking
black has a rook more uh not necessarily
i mean there is a there is a rook but in
exchange for a knight and two pawns
so
uh that take on c4 was unfortunately
necessary
there was no way for us to keep the b2
pawn and
eat the c4 pawn
see a lot of confusions
all right so do you feel comfortable
playing this against magnus
all right it's fair point yeah all right
so checking up
95 i understand i think at this point it
is understood that both players are just
trying to hold
uh black seems to be having a more
interesting attack
attacking chances towards white's king
but
at the same time black is having
troubles with his own pawns
there we go yes okay
and so i think this is also
quite equal okay maybe not equal i don't
think you close the right sword
both sides have equal fighting chances
and it's um
really hard for for one of them to
advance without
losing something in the turn so like if
you want to put more pressure on f2
you're going to lose c6
so that's why this game highly likely
that's why
this game ended in a draw see you can't
just win a pawn without losing it
without losing another one so it's like
dominoes wait actually that's not how
dominoes work
that one is like when everything goes
wrong right
okay um anyway
so now do we have two interesting
connected pass bonds
but uh black is not again hopeless black
can easily try to eat this one and try
to advance this one
so exactly it's quite double-edged
so we're gonna try to push these pawns
see again you can't just eat over here
i mean technically you could but at the
cost of this pond getting more advanced
so black is trying his best to push the
king back a little before eating some
ponds
now yay or neon take
that should be an easy answer okay yeah
yeah because
the logistics of it don't work i feel
like if my pawn was on g5 i could
consider this more seriously but because
my pawn is so
behind then i'm definitely going to lose
this it's not even worth considering
so check wait can i bring this pawn yeah
i think it's
we could easily bring this pawn but at
this point the players finally decided
that
let's try to wait yeah let's try to
throw in some checks
and it's magnus oh my god why am i
tripping a little and right now it's um
duda who decided to
not go for the draw so he didn't repeat
he simply went
for a different
way and i think this is this does try to
maximize your winning chances
but i i realistically this is this is a
draw
like you i don't care how much of a good
chances you have
right now if i push okay this is this is
gonna
kind of look like a super blunder and
highly unlikely magnus would ever
blunder this horribly he has done
inaccuracies but this type of blunder
not really
this is kind of fun because this was
like two years ago maybe three years ago
um first round of sync world cup or the
sentence rapid and blitz i remember
because i was downstairs and i was
like um helping out with the i think i
was jamming res again
and um uh it was like a super dryish end
game
and uh nepal nietzsche nepal
he blundered like with a he blundered in
a way that's like in an end game like a
rook and pawn end games
i don't remember who was the opponent
but the opponent just
uh pushed pawn gave check and ate the
rook
i think it was anna that's what i'm
thinking too
yeah and i was down and nepo came down
and he was a he was just making like
gestures with his
head and i just wanted to be like it's
okay
you'll be fine but i just looked
and judged silently so um yeah so
super grandmasters do blunder too that's
not the point the point is more like
highly unlikely anyways
so uh yeah duda is trying to poke as
much as he can about
to get magnus to blunder something but
come on it's magnus
so finally these jerks are off the board
and
this is the another little cute trick if
you take i'm going to deliver this check
and hahaha so um
that's why this is such a beautiful game
but the king is too close the rook is
too scattered
i'm the best man i'm no man i mean
sometimes i wish but that doesn't mean
i'm a woman i like it
anyways i and that's how this game
actually ended in a draw
but dude actually went on to win the
whole match between them
and he won the tournament so we like
that part about it
but this is like such a weird position
because two pawns and a knight you know
one would think that this could actually
be a win
um if you're interested in the end game
this is something that i'm going to
probably talk about
the tuesday parts of the uh
the curriculum that there is a very fun
endgame part about uh that's
the battle of alex's goryachkina versus
kostanyuk the woman's world cup that's
kostenyukwon um the
younger alex alex to the s actually
she lost the end game with the rokiana
bishop just
in a bishop rook horse's bishop that's
supposed to be a draw
but she lost it so or rather castig won
it beautifully so
that's another one that i wanted to show
but for now
i am gonna switch it to women's world
cup really quick we're not going to
spend too much time on it just like a
15 minutes really quick so this was a
very beautiful game that
goriach gonna played versus music
and sorry well i say the younger alex
because
she's my age and we actually played
together back
in 2009. i think i said that actually
once
and we drew so i want her to become the
world champion so i can
actively go around and say hey i could
have been the world champion i drew the
world champion when she was this kid so
it's for but i've never played casting
so i can't really say that
i've lost to music which i actually
showed that game
i had a better position and i showed
that game last
year it was one of my painful games it's
somewhere on
youtube i don't want to think about that
i messed up so bad
anyways all right so uh the battle of
i guess russia and ukraine oh this is
fun
um so who here plays groenfeld
sometimes well actually there is a very
nice book that the yaroslav jericho
wrote
if you play grenfell that's black do
check that out
because um yeah he's very good in chrome
field he wrote a very nice book with my
own publisher
well not my own the publisher that i
also wrote the book for
so i like promoting it i guess but yeah
um so yes if you are a grunfeld fan make
sure to
check that out and all right let's get
to the nitty gritty
all super normal openings i can't really
share much about the openings and
um we are going to kind of try to scroll
through
for the first 20 saw moves because i'm
just going to
give you a feeling of how the position
is going but
my goal for this game is to look into
about move 30th because that's when
things got really interesting
and it's really um it's really fun for
me
because music there are two sisters anna
and maria they're both really amazing
and i just
love it when i see siblings succeeding
so for me like the three polgar sisters
or the two music sisters
or any type of like other siblings that
are out there that i am not
thinking of right now it's for me it's
amazing because i have a younger brother
he's much taller much more in shape
and he's actually a better chess player
than i am right now i have better titles
so i can keep bragging about that
until he achieves those titles too uh
but no it's
it's really good because i like to kind
of give some of the credit to the
parents too so i like the whole ask the
family aspect of it
but anyways um good for the music
sisters and the polar sisters and
i can't actually think about brothers do
we know any two three brothers
that are great chess players
i don't i can't think of any i know
magnus has a
bunch of siblings i know fabiano has
siblings but i don't think that they're
that involved in chess right yeah not
really at the high level i mean
caro has a brother an older brother and
he was better for him
better than him for a while but
eventually i guess jim
and her brother shahadis those are also
a good sibling
that i can think of yeah but i can't
think of like a sin
in real high level chess so like having
two super sister
super super chess sisters
that's a very good thing all right um so
let's just keep going and um i've seen
them interact and i've always been very
encouraged by the way that they're like
close and they're just
friends because i know a lot of siblings
are not friends
okay i think when now i feel like we
need to
change this team and open up the therapy
session for siblings
oh my god let's get back to the chest of
it i don't have my
doctor's degree yet before i can start
messing with people's heads hopefully
again the evil laughter button ah
all right um in order to
for every for all of us to kind of come
back to the chest of it
how do we feel about this also chess
bras they're not
siblings actually to my knowledge
somebody's somebody mentioned chess bras
i know that both and sisters are very
uh very good at streaming but i wouldn't
say that high level just again
i have a huge respect for them and i'm
very glad for what they're doing for the
chess community
oh mahmoud yarov his sisters are very
great they're like woman grandmasters
right because i know they're two sisters
and they have the same
last names no
right so if you come up with a more
if we come up with more chess siblings
do feel free to leave a comment
now but i don't think we're going to
focus on both this game but i'm going to
leave it up for
both his sisters all right so how do we
feel white black
what's going on here
oh yeah the van forest brothers i forgot
about them
yeah i remember there was a sister too
okay there are siblings i just can't
remember them
yeah so the chat is kind of like in
white more
and yeah the black queen is a little
awkwardly placed yeah i agree
so uh we're not going to be able to trap
this queen but we can easily try to
advance our own position without that
so is there any move that is looking
good to you to
i do like the idea of castle but can we
do do we need to do something before
that
d5 e5 e5 um
maybe but the only thing with e5 is you
give up
you you block this bishop but you give
this diagonal to the opponent
so it might not be as
threatening as you would want it to be
for the opponent
so uh rook v1 is what was played very
normal move i'm gonna also stop your
bishop from moving and the next move i
wanna castle
i also moved away from this diagonal so
that's one
good aspect of it all right now we are
going to
poke around a little uh i think d5
would be interesting if my king was
already on its fun
because now there's this check and i
don't want to um
give you any more momentum and
initiative than i already have
so let's just figure out how can we
advance it
to be fair taking immediately is just
as good as um playing bishop c1 that was
played in the game
so let's just focus on bishop c1 for now
bishop c1 queen moves away
take take and at some point i do want to
do this bishop b2 but i also have to be
mindful of potential pawn eating
so let's try to save this pawn first
and all right now this knight's d4
was uh inaccurate because
you are not going to
be able to um eat this
knight immediately even if you play e5
now okay i'll have the check and the
knight is
not pinned anymore so that's the that's
the mistake that was made now queen c3
white to move what do you think we can
do and yes thank you ben
um i forgot about that i did an
interview
with the eldest van forest
three four actually 2016. so oh my god
five years ago
and um yeah he i think he mentioned
i did that for chess24 i was working for
them for a little bit back then
and he did mention this like they've had
this huge family
chess history right yeah yeah
yeah so i think that's one of the
reasons like back then
his very tiny sister which now i would
think is a teenager because
i've lost like five years ago so she was
also like 18 1900
so she should be upcoming and
interesting
but yeah the van faris family
oh my god 18 80s oh boy
oh
queen b3 is not necessarily a bad move
the issue with queen b3 is i will simply
be able to
about two things i could either take
over here first or i could take this
take back and then take this and it's
not going to be that pretty this
end game is going to most likely be
equal-ish
so rook b3 makes more sense now
when you try to move the queen now i can
eat that
but this was also a slight inaccuracy
because e5
would uh what about queen e3 right now
foreign just take it back
i don't know if k kf i don't know if
that's where you mean it
mean it's uh queen e2 right now then d4
just falls i want to try my best to
not lose the knight and that's why
instead of taking the pawn
e5 is the the the the deal because now
if you take it i have a rook d3
now the difference if i played rook d3
now you have e5
and i don't have that check that i had a
few moves ago
so we would kind of take care of this e5
problem
and when you take it then rook d3 now i
get to actually keep mine so this was a
this was a very um
sad little mistake that
alexander made oh my god i think it was
alexandra though when she was playing
stefanova a few rounds back
she blundered the whole piece right i
think that was her
i don't know i think it was heard the
chat if the chat wants to confirm but
i'm
highly certain that was her because i
was yeah yeah yeah that was her
it's stefanova and it was also funny
because music
uh anna missed a a few rounds back to
it's like a
a fun show that's
just left and right missing stuff i miss
playing high level chess
anyways so um now white is kind of stuck
in um uh
more equal end game more equal position
than if they were
if they actually kept this knight they
would not
get into this mess so because they
didn't keep this knight they entered
this
endgame of a mess well must have an end
game
and i'm going to continue for three more
moves and now
all right black made a mistake
blackboard drug c5 how can white
use it this was actually the
the biggest point of this game that i
wanted to show from the beginning
so i'll tell you what was the best move
g5 was the best move to not get the king
f4 ideas
and even if you were to eat over here
now black can simply just hold all black
has to do is hold
sometimes that waiting move on the whole
waiting game and the holding
is what gets you in trouble because
white is going to have a hard time
pushing this pawn
and all black has to do is just wait for
white
to try everything and realize that it's
not going to work out
and i know for a fact how hard that can
be because i always mess it up so
yeah um this is very drawable for
black only if black held it which they
didn't
so after to g5 would be the best one to
also cut the king so in end games it's
extremely important to cut opponent's
king
and make sure your own king has enough
space so rook c5 to defend the pawn
is a mistake simply not because king f4
can get four
although king therefore does look pretty
intriguing uh
rook c2 then the king would come back
and now you can do g5
but uh the the problem with rook c5 is
rook
c7 this is your active rook this is your
passive work so i'm gonna
get rid of your active rook we don't
like opponents active pieces so take
take
and again this trick has to go from the
one passive position to another passive
position and this gives us enough time
to
keep the stroke pinned over here and now
we will beautifully bring the king goes
considering king e5 but
i don't know where i would go after king
e5 because if king d4 there's always
going to be checks
so we can we can easily just keep the
king
um occupied over here hello matteo
you're a little bit late
we're almost done with this but yeah so
again
another mistake because if you were to
take it now another
beautiful move with the rook and double
attacking oh my god this is the pawn
structure is
making me hungry um so king h4
king g6 now this would this would give
black the best
fighting chance anyways e5
check e6 and this is
this is such a beautiful move you could
also easily just take it
take it and just do a nice waiting move
but um h5 is also quite torturing
for opponents because now if you move
the king
i will provide a check and i'll eat this
if
you move the rook i'll go after this
pawn
so yeah h5 is a very nice
devilish move i've been watching lucifer
so i keep referring to devils
so i still have one more season
all right um yes
i forgot i skipped over season four so i
actually need to go back and watch that
yes and yeah oops
oh my god yeah so um this is a very
beautiful game
yeah that's rook c5 and rook c7 that was
a very very interesting
um way to
convert the advantage in the end game
but anyways like right now this is this
pawn is
dropping so white tries to um
well actually black tries to actually
have no idea what black's trying to do
so i guess it's just desperation
desperation
but yeah black is kind of just lost
there's no no real point
black's rook didn't really get to
disrupt until they get to leave the
eighth rank
and the king was just stuck and the pawn
structures were just miserable so
um yeah that's one of the games that i
definitely wanted to go over
uh most likely go over the battle level
alex's
on our tuesday and potentially wednesday
sessions
so feel free to tune in for those um if
you are in san luis make sure to join us
tomorrow live from five oh actually
in person from five to six because we
are going to be doing
cool tactics in person and then there's
quads i believe
right hopefully there's you there's
usually quads so make sure to call and
double check
and feel free to leave comments
subscribe and
yeah i'll see you later
[Music]
you